startups that are not smaller versions  of large companies large companies at  their core execute known and proven  business models but startups startups do  something radically different than their  first year or two startups actually  search for a business model and it's  this distinction between execution and  search that now makes us think that  perhaps we need a new set of tools for  early-stage ventures that we never had  before and my contribution was the  beginning of thinking through what is  that entrepreneurial management stack  for search that parallels the execution  stack that we built up in business  schools for the last hundred years  you